hey ralph while i got you on the phone
did you and chris watch aaron carter
jerk off on friday night
what is that and chris paid like five
bucks for it what is going on there
who didn't who didn't watch aaron carter
trigger now how do you get to see that
something like that
it was in page six and i found out oh
they're doing this tonight
i bought it because i was i was curious
he started off
nude right away nude no [ __ ] and
he's a huge [ __ ]
like like even flaccid is hot his [ __ ]
is huge and they started playing guitar
and he was singing some of his hits with
his with his big [ __ ] out
but i i will say he blew a huge
load and at the end as a bonus he showed
off his feet and shaved his pubes
oh really you mean after this was a pack
a jam-packed
show for some reason
[Laughter]
[Music]
his money your money's worth hey the
guy's an entertainer
let's be honest and was ralph on there
for the load did he get on on time
well ralph commented on the load what
did you say ralph i don't know
i don't know something at least at least
[Music]
sounds like a completely normal
heterosexual friday night i'll be honest
with you
let me be clear i didn't log in and pay
for chris was sending me screenshots
right
hey you're cheap [ __ ] chris is on the
couch next to his mother
the whole time
we were watching television i went up to
canada to go i hadn't seen her in six
months and it was my last night there
and i found out
that this was going to be on the air it
was going to be it was going to be live
i i wasn't playing with myself if she
could see the computer screen
well she it was on my phone and at one
time one point i turned up the volume
and aaron's going like
no hole picks guys i'm not going to show
my hole
and my mom goes what what is that and i
said oh
it's something for work it's stupid
ralph were you bummed that he didn't
show his hull
yes
send me the picture dude i want to see
oh my god in heaven what the [ __ ]
oh my god what did you see
did you see the logo i see a [ __ ]
load on a mirror or something man
dude listen you know how you always say
like if you were a good looking guy
would be perfect this is a good looking
guy look at what he's busy doing
yeah he got your money only got chris's
money anyway
by the way boys how were his balls
very nice low hangers you didn't send me
that picture man come on
i didn't get your cheap [ __ ] pay for the
stream like i did
by the way i asked ralph about the
software and he says it's not gay if you
don't pay for it so